All right. Well, let's uh
let's get uh get started here. I did see
a couple people walk in at uh kind of
last minute. Um if you haven't already
uh read the slide there, uh you'll
notice the slide has the uh first bit of
instructions. Uh send an email. That
email address that you see right up
there, so pecjohnplusaiworld@github.com,
and then just as the subject, just put
in your GitHub handle. One quick note
about the GitHub handle, if you are
using enterprise managed users, uh this
is going to need to be a personal um
GitHub handle. So, that email address,
and then
your GitHub handle as the uh as the
subject. Again, not
but
you know what to do. So, go ahead and uh
and do that. And uh while everybody's uh
getting settled in, uh let's go ahead
and get rockin' and rollin'. So, uh my
name is Christopher Harrison. Uh the
gentleman over there is uh John Peck.
And uh we are both uh enterprise
advocates at uh GitHub, uh obviously
doing a whole lot of uh developer
relations stuff. So, basically talking
to customers and uh doing events like
this, primarily focused in on developer
experience in this little thing called
GitHub Copilot. So, this is going to
hopefully be a hands-on lab. Now, I am
going to put out a couple of real quick
caveats, because we had the exact same
lab this morning, and we ran into a
couple of challenges, the biggest of
which with the Wi-Fi network. That
because of what we're going to be doing
is going to rely quite heavily on the
network, we're going to try, okay? I'm
going to repeat that one more time. We
are going to try. We're going to give it
our best effort.
If it works, wonderful. And if it
doesn't work, here's what we're we're to
do instead. Is you will still have a day
or two to be able to complete the lab
and you can go ahead and complete that
on your own time. And what I will do
instead is I will start doing some
demos. I will answer a whole bunch of
questions.
The morning group had a whole bunch of
questions and something tells me that
this group will also have a whole bunch
of questions. Been doing enough Copilot
talks, there always seems to be an awful
lot of questions. More than happy to
talk through all of that. So, we're
going to try our absolute best.
Hopefully everything will work and if it
doesn't work, we've got a nice little
fallback. And I want to make sure again
that I highlight you will have access to
the lab for a couple of days after this
event so that way you could go out and
do it on on your own time from from
there.
So, one last time because I did see a
couple of people that just walked in.
Notice instructions on the slide. Please
send an email
to John plus AI World at github.com. For
the subject, just put in your GitHub
handle again. Make sure that's your
personal or a non-enterprise managed
user account. If you don't know what
enterprise managed users are, don't
worry about it cuz then you probably
don't have one. If you have one, you'll
know it.
See a couple of knowing nods there.
Okay. Without any further delay, let's
go ahead and talk a little bit about
GitHub Copilot. So, John's going to be
working in the background here. Once
he is done working, I'm then going to go
ahead and make an introduction and get
everybody pointed at the at the lab. But
I want to get started by talking about
something that's very very important
when we're working with GitHub Copilot
and that is context. That you'll notice
that we have a tagline for GitHub
Copilot called your AI pair programmer.
Now, not only is it wonderful marketing,
kind of is, but it's also a fantastic
description of how best to think about
GitHub Copilot. That you want to think
about it as an AI pair programmer.
And the example that I always give, the
analogy that I always give, is my
partner and I woke up the other day and
she says to me, "Hey, I want to go to
brunch." Fantastic. Who doesn't love
brunch? And so, I recommend that a spot
and she looks at me and says, "You know,
here's the thing.
Been there an awful lot lately. I want
to go somewhere new."
Okay, fantastic. And then I recommend
that another spot.
And then she says, "You know, now that
I'm thinking about it, I'm really kind
of craving waffles." Spectacular. Who
doesn't love waffles? And then I
recommend that another spot. Now, that's
a very normal back and forth.
That what happened was is a request was
made, I had some level of context, and I
gave back a perfectly valid response.
And then some more context was provided.
And then I gave yet another response.
And that's a very common back and forth.
And that may have been context that she
had at the very beginning and maybe just
hadn't yet shared. And it might also
have been context that she sort of
discovered as we were talking. Again,
all of this is very, very normal and
it's how we think about when we're
talking about with other people, when
we're talking with human pair
programmers, and then also in turn with
that AI pair programmer. That context is
key.
Now, when we're talking about context, a
lot of times, we really focus in on the
prompt when we're talking about context
and AI.
That I see an awful lot, especially with
new developers to uh to Copilot, is
they're really worried about like,
"Okay, well, how do I craft a prompt?"
And don't get me wrong, prompt crafting
is an important skill.
But context goes beyond prompt crafting.
Because unlike a lot of other tools,
which are maybe going to run all of your
code through different parsers or maybe
even build your code or potentially even
like run your code,
Copilot again behaves like an AI pair
programmer. It's going to be reading
your code.
Just as if I brought somebody else new
onto the team and they're going to start
reading your code. So, making sure that
that code is readable
becomes very important. So, if you have
a good function names, good variable
names,
your code is well structured, Copilot's
going to be able to navigate that pretty
well.
And if you're using a lot of single
letter variables,
you're using a lot of abbreviations,
Copilot's going to come along and it's
going to struggle with that, just again,
as another pair programmer would.
In addition,
comments. Now, we all know the point the
importance of commenting code. And there
is a strong part of me that has this
feeling that good code doesn't need
comments.
But here's the thing,
is having a line or two of comments
does help you make your code that much
more readable.
And so, even if it might be superfluous,
if it's going to make life easier, maybe
just go ahead and add that in, cuz it's
not going to, say, slow down your
application. So, having comments
describing what it is that you're going
to be doing, how it is that you're going
to be doing it, is really going to help
things out.
And then finally, last but not least, is
your project structure.
That having a good navigable project
structure
is also going to help Copilot. Now, the
real takeaway that I want you to get out
of all of this is this is sort of like
just good code 101.
That having good code is really going to
help out an awful lot with context. I'm
going to come back to to questions a
little bit later.
Okay.
So, how do we then help Copilot help us?
And so, number one, context, we talked
about that. Number two, the intent.
Make sure that you're clear about the
intent. What is it that you are trying
to do?
And be clear about that intent.
Now, one of the things that I see an
awful lot of developers do, especially
if they've maybe worked with like other
chatbots,
is when they start sending those initial
prompts,
that they're very terse.
because they're used to dealing with
older chatbots that maybe weren't really
good at processing natural language. And
so it basically became like using
command lines.
That's not what this is built for. So be
clear. If you want something to be done
a particular way and kind of getting
into the specificity aspect here, tell
Copilot or as I like to say, don't be
passive-aggressive
with Copilot.
That sometimes I'll see a new developer
or they'll go in, they'll they'll
they'll give like a very short prompt
and then they'll go, "Well, wait a
minute. Why didn't Copilot figure this
part out?"
Well, did you know that part? Well,
yeah. Did you tell Copilot? Well, no.
Okay, well, tell Copilot. Like if
there's an important piece of
information that you need Copilot to
consider, go ahead and make sure that
you tell Copilot that.
Okay.
Now,
Copilot supports a handful of different
workloads.
Um you'll notice the one on the far end,
Copilot coding agent. I'll get to that
one in a minute. It's all bright and
sparkly and so forth. Um that's not
because that one's um necessarily best.
Um it's just because it's the newest and
as we all know, we need to just
highlight and sparkle as the um the the
the newest item.
So,
um first up, let's talk about code
completions. So code completion is sort
of the original version, if you will, of
GitHub Copilot. This is where I'm going
in, I'm writing code, and then Copilot
will suggest the next line, it will
suggest the next function, and it will
suggest the next class. This is
wonderful. If you're in the zone, you
know what you're doing, you're typing
away, fantastic. And Copilot will be
able to support you right there.
Next up is chat. And originally, this
was single shot. That I go in, I ask a
question, and I get a response back. So
maybe it can generate a single file for
me.
But the problem with that is if we think
about even the simplest of updates, like
if I go to update a webpage, I'm going
to be updating an HTML, JavaScript, and
CSS file.
That's multiple files.
And so this is where edits comes play.
And with edits, Copilot is now able to
edit across multiple files.
And then we take that to the next level
with agent mode.
And with agent mode, now again still
inside my IDE,
what Copilot's going to be able to do is
navigate your project,
figure out what needs to be done, and
then start building code. And it's able
to work iteratively, and it's able to
run external tasks, like for example,
running your unit tests.
And if it detects, "Hey, there's an
error," it's even able to self-heal. I'm
going to sneeze.
Thank you.
Okay. I I was waiting for the second
one. I usually sneeze in twos. It'll
It'll It'll show up in a minute here.
Um okay. Um and then finally we get into
coding agent.
And coding agent is different because
this is going to be done inside of
github.com.
So I'll have an issue on github.com, and
I can then assign that to coding agent.
And coding agent will then work in the
background,
figure out what needs to be done,
be able to again run scripts, be able to
self-heal, and then eventually create a
a pull request that you can then review,
and eventually merge into your code
base.
And so this is what we're going to be
exploring. Not going to worry too much
about these two slides here. There we
go. This is what we're going to be
exploring in this lab. John, how we
doing?
We are doing splendid. I have two people
left to add to the board.
I will need about 3 minutes to add them
all to Copilot.
Okay, but we can at least go in and
start accepting invitations.
go in and start accepting invitations.
One quick note, um Michael Pope, I don't
believe I have your correct handle. So
if you could send me a new one, that
would be great. Okay, and there was one
person who walked in just a minute ago,
so we'll need to get that sorted as
well, but we can get there in a minute.
Okay. So,
um first part to the lab.
Navigate to the URL that you see right
there. So, getup.com/octo
uh HOL hands-on on lab. So, O C T O H O
L. Hotel Oscar Lima.
And then at the very top and by the way,
I'm assuming that you're logged into
GitHub with the handle that you sent
over.
And then up towards the very top, you
should see accept invitation.
And then go ahead and select accept
invitation.
Now, here's the most important part
about today.
Silence means hey, everything is
fantastic.
So, if you're not seeing it, please let
me know.
Uh
Okay.
And then accept invitation right at the
very top. Okay.
Yep.
Did you send the email?
Okay.
All right.
Um I'll come back in a second.
Um
Hey John.
Do they need to ask for the copilot
seat?
Um they need to explicitly ask. I am
just going through the process right now
of adding those in. Okay. Perfect.
It doesn't matter. Yeah, he's he's going
to be adding you in. Okay. Now, for
anybody who did not send the email
address,
um
please go ahead and send an email
to that address.
And then with your GitHub handle, I'm
going to leave that up for about another
15 seconds here because I'm trying to
keep things moving
for everybody as quick as I best can
here.
Um the uh I can share the uh share the
slide deck. Um my handle is uh geek
trainer and you can um basically find me
on everywhere with uh with that
including GitHub.
Geek trainer. G E E K?
Trainer.
Um uh GitHub at GitHub.
Okay.
Now then,
let me
get
everybody rolling here. So,
after you have accepted the invitation,
um who has not yet accepted the
invitation?
Okay. And then what happened when you
went to OctoHaul? And by the way, I I
want to make sure that I highlight
something. You'll you'll notice that
more people raised hands, silence means
everything is fantastic. So, if
something is not working, please let me
know. Now, for people who um everything
is working fantastic, then here's what
you can do is go to that URL.
Actually going to modify the slide real
quick.
Is
And if we could get phones to a silent
or a vibrate, that would be wonderful.
Okay.
All right.
So, um
to get started with the lab,
what you're going to do, navigate to
that URL that you see right there. So,
gh.io/agent-sdlc-lab.
When you get to the part to create your
repository,
the owner is going to be octo-hol,
and then the name is going to be your
handle, again replacing your
See where that's going.
And go ahead and start working on
exercises zero
and exercises one.
And I will let you have at it, and then
I'm going to start going around and
helping people get unstuck.
Okay.
Um
Hey John. Yeah. When uh when you have a
minute?
Okay.
Uh right over here.
Did you send the email? Yes. Okay. Um
we'll go ahead and get John over to help
you out in a minute.
Yes.
Okay.
Did um was it maybe there earlier?
Do me a favor. Um hit plus right at the
top here.
Yeah, and then hit new repository.
Just let's just test something real
quick.
Um hit the um drop down right here. Um
okay. We'll go ahead and get John John
over here in just a minute. Sorry. Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Now then,
remember, silence means everything is
everything is fantastic. So, if
something is not working, please raise
your hand, otherwise we are never going
to know.
Oh, okay. So, not the owner? So, owner
is going to be octocat?
No.
So, notice the slide. Okay, sorry. Yep.
And then, the repository name is going
to be your handle. There you go. Yep.
Hey.
Um okay, then hold on for just a minute.
John will be over.
Hi.
Oh, oh okay. So, here's what we need to
do. Hi.
Um
Yep.
No, um so, yep. Uh perfect. So, go ahead
and hit enter.
And so, go ahead and scroll down. And
you see the step zero here, set the
environment. Let's go ahead and just hit
that.
And then now we're going to follow the
instructions from here. So, you'll
notice that you're going to want to open
up the
um that URL in a new tab, and then
you're going to select uh use a
template, and then create from that.
You're welcome.
All right.
How's everybody doing?
I know there's a couple of people that
John's going around to. Yeah.
Yes.
Yep.
Beautiful.
Doesn't matter.
Living on the edge.
Yeah.
Nope. Um, here's what you're going to do
is um,
so uh, go to Okay. So, go to um, docs.
And then just scroll on down and um, go
to step zero.
And then now go ahead and follow right
along with what this says here.
Yeah.
Oh, okay. So, nope. So, um, we um, we
need to go to the first part here. So,
navigate to that URL here.
So, go to
Yep. So, um, real quick as people are
getting started, I want everybody to
kind of notice the the steps on the
slide here. So, step one is go here.
What you're going to find there is a set
of instructions for the hands-on lab.
And then in step zero, it's going to
have you then create your repository.
When you get to that step, you're going
to set the owner to octo HOL and then
the name to your your handle. So, start
here, start working through the lab, and
then you're going to go in and um,
uh, and set that up.
Okay. So, let's go into step zero.
Yep. And then now you'll notice it's
going to have you um, open that up in a
new tab. It's going to have you create
from Exactly. Yep. And then you're all
set.
Don't sit down yet.
Yes, just start at zero.
Okay, so here's what we need to do is
let's go ahead and
let's just go to
Nope.
You see the URL up at the very top
there, the gh.io? Okay.
Nope, it looked like we
didn't
it should be sdlc. So, let's go ahead
and just try that again. So, type in
type nope, nope, stop. Yep, there we go.
So, gh.io
/agent
sdlc
Nope, nope. You have an sl, we want
sdlc. Yep, -lab.
Enter.
There we go. And so now go ahead and
scroll on down.
And then you'll notice there's step
zero. Let's go ahead and go right in on
step zero.
And then now it's going to have you
create your repository. So, if we read
through, we'll notice step one, we'll
open that URL up in a brand new tab, and
then follow the instructions from there.
Okay, so
um I'm here. Yep.
Nope.
Create new repository.
Yep.
Nope. Put it into as it says up on the
slide. Hit the drop down.
octohall
And then the repository name will be
your handle.
Uh you can leave it as private. That's
fine.
Okay.
All right. You're welcome.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Yeah, you can just go ahead and delete
that one. And then Okay, so all you have
to do is go to settings.
Scroll all the way down. All the way.
Yep, there we go. And then um hit that.
And then you're going to hit delete.
And you're going to um you can actually
just copy and paste it.
Um and then uh yeah.
Welcome.
Yo.
Correct.
Yeah, we can leave that unmerged. Yep.
Yeah. Yeah. We're just going in and and
kind of exploring it. There's also
um
Yeah, I'll get to that in a minute. Ask
me that question again in in 5 minutes.
I don't want to interrupt everybody, but
it's there's an important thing there.
So, ask me that question again in 5
minutes.
Yeah.
Is it in this? I opened that specific
lab, but I don't see use template or
anything.
Oh, yeah, you need to be signed in.
There you go.
Yeah.
Perfect.
Correct.
Yep. Yeah. And And just kind of keep on
following on with the uh with the lab
from there. What this is going to have
you do in a minute here is it's going to
have you open up um the your repository
again and then you're going to create a
couple of issues and start playing
around with coding agent.
Yep.
There might be some code spaces where
the actual Git connection hasn't
established yet cuz that happens after
you Yep.
Yeah. You've all done that's uh the the
lab actually says to send a a hello
um to like um
um kind of wake it up. Oh, okay. Yeah.
We We We had played with that.
I know.
Keep going.
Yeah.
Fantastic.
Oh. Hey John.
He's having the premium requests, Sarah.
Oh, thank you.
I type really really fast. I don't type
I type accurately, but I type really
really fast.
You see here's the thing about being a
developer, you don't have to spell
correctly. You just have to spell
consistently.
Yeah.
Yes.
Yeah, actually if you're you know, if
you're like in a in a zone and you
already like finish out step one and
want to start getting into step two, you
can go ahead and do that. You'll also
notice that all of the steps actually
include like little optional exercises.
So, if you are um you know, uh somebody
who kind of like just moves really
really fast, um there's other stuff to
do in in in that lab. So, yeah. So, go
ahead and um kind of keep working
through exercise one. Um I'm going to do
a an overview of exercise one in like
just a couple of minutes here.
For CodeSpaces? No, so CodeSpaces is a
separate product. The reason that we're
using code spaces is it's effectively a
container in the cloud and so it just
eliminates setup. So, like it's
wonderful for just development in
general, but especially something like
this having people install software,
forget it. So, yeah.
Christopher.
Does it work?
So, Copilot uh for enterprise, which is
going to be like everything that we're
using, is $39.99. A month or
a month? Yeah. Um uh there's also a
business tier, which does not um it
there's a few different features that it
doesn't include, um but one of the
biggest is going to be um access to uh
to coding agent. Um and that's at $20 a
month or again, $19.99 or whatever.
Uh yeah. Yep.
Yeah. Yep. Yeah. Yeah.
Um hit refresh real quick.
It's on? Yeah.
Um
Do you still have
There we go.
All right. So, um here's what I'm going
to do. I know that people are still
working. Um periodically, I'm just going
to come up here. I'm going to kind of
talk and highlight a little bit about a
feature. So, this is basically um a real
quick overview of what it is that you're
doing in exercise uh one. You can have a
seat.
Make yourself comfortable.
Pretend like you're an adult.
Do I look like an adult? No.
Proof that you work with somebody for
way too long. Um
No. So, um so, let's talk a little bit
about um GitHub Copilot coding agent.
So, the whole goal of Coding Agent is to
have a
um an AI peer programmer. That what I
can do is I can assign it a Copilot
issue or uh sorry, a GitHub issue and
let Copilot begin work on it. Now, the
first big thing about assigning an issue
to Copilot, remember that whole speech
we did about context, waffles, all that
good stuff, yeah, yeah, so context.
Context is key. And so, if we take a
look at the issue that we created,
we went ahead and gave it a pretty
decent amount of detail about what it
was that we wanted to have accomplished.
So, you'll notice that we're going to be
creating a uh functionality to allow for
submission of games. So, here's all of
our requirements and kind of list them
all out. And if this was going to be
something more robust, I might have even
dropped a um a potential workflow that I
wanted it to kind of step through as it
was building out all of the project.
Again, don't be passive-aggressive with
Copilot. That if there's some piece of
information you want it to see and
understand, absolutely 100% tell it
about it.
Now, the next thing is after you assign
it, it needs an environment in which to
work.
And there is an uh there's a workflow
that you can create
and it's called, he said speaking slowly
to stall,
um Copilot setup steps.
And so, when Copilot goes to do its
work,
it's going to be running inside of
GitHub Actions
and it's going to step zero
run everything that it sees inside this
workflow. And if you look through this
workflow, what you're going to notice a
whole bunch of steps to install
different services and packages and so
forth. And that's now going to be the
environment in which it's able to do its
thing.
Now, that also leads me to another very
big point, which is about security.
Because here's what I'm going to do.
Is I'm going to take an AI agent.
I'm going to assign it a task.
And it's now able to go off and start
doing things.
And I want to make sure that everything
that's going to be doing is going to be
completely contained.
So, the first big thing
about working with coding agent
is that it does not have access to
the internet.
That by default, it is a firewall that's
going to block it from any external
resource.
Now, you do have an ability
to open up the firewall if you do want
it to be able to access external
resources, but by default it won't. And
that includes, by the way, installing
frameworks and libraries.
So, the only way it's going to have
access to frameworks and libraries is
either A, you open up holes in the
firewall, or B,
you set this up to install all the
necessary libraries. Number two.
This is running inside of GitHub
Actions. And if you're not already
familiar with GitHub Actions, one great
thing about it is that it's going to
launch in a femoral space. So, it's
going to set up a space. It's going to
do its work inside of there. And then
it's going to collapse down from there.
So, it will not have access to any other
resources besides what's inside of
there. Number three.
It does not have write access to your
repository save for the branch that it
creates.
So, it cannot modify anything inside
your code base. The only thing it's able
to modify is just its branch.
Number four.
That branch, you're going to notice,
will not actually create a full pull
request. It's going to leave that in
draft form, not become an actual pull
request unless you come along and say,
"Yes, I approve this." Number five.
Along those lines, if you are a good
developer shop, and you have different
requirements, things like security
checks, things like unit tests,
end-to-end tests, regression tests, all
of which need to pass, what you're also
going to notice is that on this pull
request, none of that can actually run
Where's that button? Right there. Until
you click that button that says approve
workflow runs. So again, trying to keep
it completely self-contained. And then
finally, last but not least, and this
was a question that was asked earlier
about reviewing it and then merging it
in.
When it comes to the current version of
coding agent, there is a restriction,
and this is by design. Um remember
again, coding agent is brand new, so
this can always change, but this is by
design, that if you assign an issue to
coding agent, you are not allowed to
then review its work. So you need
somebody else to review its work. So
basically, it's sort of like in most
organizations, you're not allowed to
review your own work, you need to bring
somebody else in. Sort of the same thing
is that I assign the peer programmer,
and then I need somebody else to come
along and say yes, that this actually uh
that this actually is okay.
All right.
So questions on Copilot coding agent.
That is a fantastic question.
And I'm just going to say that that is a
fantastic question.
And and and I'm going to say that's a
Um other questions?
That's a great question. So the question
is That was also a great question. Um so
the question is can you iterate? The
answer is yes. Is um what I can do um
let me zoom out a little bit. That was a
little obnoxious. Um, is I can just go
in and add a comment. So, if I go in and
I add a comment and I say, "Hey,
um,
what what I potentially want it to do,
um, also add in an endpoint to search
for games by name." There we go.
Thank you.
And if I scroll back up, give it just a
second here,
and then we'll notice the cute little
eyeballs again. So, now,
what's happening is that Copilot has
started work again. And if I hit view
session,
hopefully I've stalled just long enough
here,
you'll notice that it's actually started
up a brand new session. So, it's going
to take the work that it did and then
it's going to start back up again and
begin work again from there.
Yeah. Does it work with self-hosted
runners?
No.
Not at the moment.
When?
I I I I shouldn't have even said at the
moment.
Let's uh let's let's summarize that
answer. No.
Uh yeah. Great. Yeah. Is
If you were I always feel like a press
secretary whenever I'm doing this.
And can you run Copilot
uh on behalf of other organizations? If
you have a GitHub app and you have other
companies that integrate with it, can
you run a GitHub Copilot on behalf of
them or do you have to just run that
yourself? So,
um,
give me a little bit more about what
you're asking there. Yeah, so I have a
GitHub application and clients install
my GitHub application. It generates
enriched prompts that we want to use
with basically GitHub Copilot to run
something on their code base. Can we do
that? No. Okay. So, what you could do is
you could stand up an MCP server, so
that way they could use Copilot, talk to
your code, and then start to interact
that way. But, you're not going to be
able to have Copilot like do something
to somebody else's code base. Okay. So,
it's not like an open API that you can
just have a co-pilot sticking in a code
base to do something. No. Yeah. Yeah.
So, I think we cannot leverage like
So, yeah. So, what you can do is if you
have a pull request, you can assign that
to to co-pilot at that point. But again,
it needs to be on a repository that you
own.
Okay. So, if we
install the app, so it's of course in
their repo,
and we can technically assign the
co-pilot to do some work as well from
the company client.
Yeah.
Right?
I don't know the answer to that. I'm I'm
going to be honest. I I don't know the
answer to cuz I don't know necessarily
like what an app is able to do on
on behalf of the user at that point. Um
I Yeah, I would I
I I I would need to get back to you on
that. Yeah. My my handle is Geek
Trainer. Let me just
Um
Ah.
There we go.
So, just shoot me an email and I can try
and dig up a
a more robust answer for you. Other
questions? Yeah.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Yeah, this is a This is a great question
and I'm actually going to up level this
um a little bit. So, when we're talking
specifically about coding agent, if it
doesn't do um something that that uh
that I wanted it to or if it does get
something completely wrong, and keep in
mind that AI, just like human
developers, is going to periodically get
things wrong and it's sometimes going to
get things spectacularly wrong. Again,
just like humans are going to sometimes
get things spectacularly wrong. So,
um if that's the case, there's a few
different approaches that I could take.
So, one of them would be is, just like I
did um here a minute
uh ago, is or 3 minutes 57 seconds ago,
but who's counting? Um is just add in a
comment and just clarify, "Hey, this is
really what I want to use." So, that's
one option. Um if it's like completely
wrong, if it's just um completely out of
left field, then the next option is you
can just go back um all the way up to
the very top here um and under
assignees, um and I'm not going to
remove this cuz I I want to let it keep
doing its thing, but just unassign
Copilot,
change your issue, and then reassign
Copilot.
And then and then that way it will just
completely start from from scratch.
Um number three,
and I think this is always um
very important when when we're working
with AI, is if we see it get something
wrong, one of the first questions that
we really want to be asking is why did
it get it wrong? And nine times out of
10, and I I'm going to come right back
to this word yet again, is context. Is
that it didn't fully understand not only
just your request, but in the
environment in which it was going to be
working. So, one of my absolute um
favorite features um is
um Copilot instructions.
So, on Copilot instructions, what you're
going to notice, and this is read um in
um in coding agent, and it's also read
on every single um chat request,
Oh, how do I
um
Yes.
I figured out a shortcut key on a Mac.
Go me.
Thank you.
Um
Hey.
but what you're going to notice here is
I have copilot-instructions.md.
This is looked at by coding agent, and
it's also looked at by every single chat
request that I make inside the IDE. And
what you're going to notice in here is I
have a really nice high-level overview
of what I'm doing and how it is that I'm
doing it. So, I've given it a little bit
of introduction about the app itself and
how it is that I'm building it. I've
given it code standards. I've told it
everything that's required before
commit. I gave it some global language
guidance, and then I gave it some
specifics on on what it is that I'm
building and how it is that I want it to
be built. And then if I scroll all the
way down, you'll even notice that I
highlighted that repository structure,
so that way I'm clearly spelling out
this is where to go find things. So,
this is a big place to go in and look if
you want Copilot to have some additional
context, some additional information. Um
another big thing that you can do, again
speaking to things that both coding
agent and Copilot Chat are are able to
use, is to stand up an MCP server. So,
this is actually one of the other
exercises in the lab um is Model Context
Protocol, and basically what an MCP
server allows you to do, and I have a
slide
right here that shows you the uh the
diagram. I need everybody to memorize
this diagram. There's going to be a quiz
on this later.
Fantastic. Um
But basically, here's what happened. If
somebody goes in, they make a request to
Copilot, Copilot can then look through
the list of commands that have been
exposed out through different MCP
servers, and then from there go access
external data. Because this is always
one of the challenges whenever I'm
working with Copilot, or really anything
that's built on top of an LLM, is that
typically it's going to be limited to
just that training set, and that's it.
This allows it to access external
information, and even perform operations
on your behalf as well. So, if you see
Copilot coding agent doing things in a
way that you weren't quite expecting,
take a look at its context, take a look
at what it has. So, look at your Copilot
instructions, maybe put an MCP server.
So, if you've got like a really
large repo, a really large code base,
and you want Copilot to be able to like
better search and better reason over
that, this is a place where like
standing up an MCP server would come
into come into play. Now, I do want to
highlight one last thing,
um
because Harold is in the room, and
he would be very disappointed in me if I
didn't highlight this. And this is dot
instructions files,
which and I am not saying this just
because Harold is in the room. This is
one of the
things that that Harold works on.
I'm not saying that just because he is
here. This is true. This is one of my
absolute favorite little features,
where when we think about what we're
doing in coding,
is we're doing a lot of the same thing
over and over again. Like, I'm going in
and I'm creating yet another React
component, or in this case here, I'm
creating yet another Flask endpoint.
But, I probably want all of those to
follow a particular pattern. And so,
what I can do is I can create a dot
instructions file, and I can then
manually add this into chat, and this
dot instructions file can then have
information about how it is that I want
it to be created, the different rules
around it, and then even point to
prototype files that basically say,
"Hey, you You that games file over
there? Use that. That's how I want this
to be built. Hey, you see that test
file? Use that. That's how I want it to
be built.
And I can even have this happen
automatically that you'll notice that I
have apply to header and valve.
And so now if it matches this pattern,
so if it's inside the server test folder
and starts with test underscore, it's
going to automatically apply that. So
let's say again going to react
components, I can then go ahead and set
up a filter so anything that ends with a
JSX TSX
extension, I want it to apply this. If
you're a spell developer like I am,
um
All right. Okay. All right. I got a
couple of people. Fantastic. Beautiful.
Um then I can go ahead and set up a
pattern so that anything that ends with
dot spell is going to follow the
instructions here. Now again, this part
here right now only available inside of
Co-pilot Chat, but again, other ways
that I can start to provide context.
That was an awful lot of context. There
was a question over here. Yeah.
How often do you update this?
Is that part of your software
development life cycle? Yeah, this is a
great question is
how often do I do you update this? Keep
in mind that this is an artifact of your
repository and I very much want to treat
that as such. So
I sort of give this an analogy to you
know those little scripts that you spend
like three days writing, but it's going
to save you five minutes a day?
That's basically what these are is that
you're going to spend some time and you
really should create your instructions
file, create your dot instructions file.
Like really make these robust because
what you're going to wind up with then
on the back end is increased
productivity, but you're also then going
to help ensure that the code that's
being generated is generated the way
that you want it to be generated. So as
things change then do that. Yes, Mr.
Harold. Yeah. What if there is anything
that you have made mistakes you want to
correct it?
So let's say you got it on the on the
and you start minimal and then you
adding to it.
Yeah. And I would even add like to that
that you know, one of the things that's
relatively unique about being in DevRel
is I do an awful lot of demos.
And one of the things about doing a demo
is you need that to work.
And doing that with a probabilistic tool
like GitHub Copilot
does become a little bit of an
adventure. That will be the word that I
will use there.
And instructions files have been
probably the number one thing that I
have leaned on to help ensure that I get
some level of consistency. So I really
can't overstate the importance of
instructions file. And again, I'm not
just saying that cuz Harold's in the
room.
Yeah.
Well, when you make those. Yep,
absolutely. Yeah.
Yep.
So
So the the question is is that hey,
inside your issue you told it something
that it probably should have been able
to find elsewhere. That it was inside
the instruction file
and and you still typed it out. Like you
know, do you really need to do that?
Fantastic question. So I'm I'm going to
answer that directly, but then I'm also
going to uplevel that
as well. So to answer to directly, I
really didn't need to. Um but this
really again kind of falls under that
category of like not being passive
aggressive with Copilot. Like if there's
something that I know, typing it out
isn't going to hurt anything. So adding
that to that, if anything it's just
going to help it because now I'm just
like further reinforcing the fact that
hey, this does need to to to actually
work. Um now I am going to up-level real
quick because I think this also then
brings up another question, which is
hey, now we've got the issue here. Um
and especially like if I'm working with
um with Copilot Chat, where now I could
have like a dot instructions file. And
we've already seen that I can have those
call other files. And then now I've got
my Copilot instructions. And so that
then kind of begs the next question,
which is well, is there a hierarchy
here? And the answer is no, that there
isn't any form of a last right, that
it's going to consider all of that
context and then make its best decision
from there. Which also then kind of
leads to another thing which we should
really be focused in on like John was
highlighting with like our team leads is
let's try to be consistent. So let's not
start sending mixed messages because
just like if we start sending mixed
messages to our team and they're going
to get confused, the exact same thing is
going to happen with uh with Copilot.
Yeah.
Uh I can open up holes in the firewall.
So um if I'm using MCP locally from
inside VS Code, good to go. If um I'm
getting coding agent to do that, then um
when I add in the MCP server, I also
need to open up the firewall. All of
it's actually really well documented um
um uh to to highlight all of that, but
yes. The short answer is yes.
Yeah, so
so when you go in and and configure
that, you can do that at the repo level.
I believe you can do that at the org
level as well. And then what you do is
you then set variables
and you can do that again at the repo
level or you can do that at the
organization level. So you can
centralize all of that.
Can you review the code and fix that and
then restart the whole session
versus like the minute
like just review this file and make sure
you fix this file?
Um
so
I'm going to I I I'm going to inject my
own question into that first and then
I'm going to come back and answer that
question. So the first question is can
you review the code? And I I I want to
make sure that I I mention this because
it's so incredibly important. Um AI does
not change
the DevOps flow. That if I think about
how I wrote code before AI, um I would
write code off my own memory. I would be
writing code based on code that I'm
seeing elsewhere. I would write code by
copying and pasting from Stack Overflow
making a couple of changes and then just
crossing my fingers and hoping and
praying that it works.
Or maybe that's just me.
Or maybe I'm just the only one willing
to admit it. Um
So in
in that situation, what do I have? I
have a DevOps flow where I'm going to
get John to come along and and review
it. I'm going to have linters that are
going to come in and check to make sure
that I'm following all my standards. I'm
going to have security scans that are
going to look for any potential
vulnerabilities. Then I'm and I have all
of these different things, all of these
these these these safeguards to help
ensure that the code that gets into my
code base is secure and is written the
exact way that we want it to be written.
When I'm using AI, all of that still
stands. So
I want my manual code reviews. I want my
security checks. I want my linters. I
want my unit tests. I want all of that
to go in and run. Now,
to get specific to
um the the second half of your question
there, which is, "Hey, it's just this
one file that I want you to look at." Um
when I'm working with coding agent,
um or really Copilot in general, there's
always a non-zero chance that it's not
going to follow what you want it to do
exactly. So, if I say, "Hey, go in and
update this file." It it might work
specifically on that file and really in
particular when I'm working about with
with agent mode, it might work with that
one file, but it also might do a couple
of other things as well. And there's not
necessarily a way to guarantee that it's
only going to do just that. If you want
it to only ever do just like that one
particular file, this is where like edit
mode comes into play. This is where ask
mode comes into play inside my IDE
because in those situations, I'm
steering rather than letting um
um uh then uh then then letting Copilot
steer.
So, can I just So, when you review the
code, it's going to start a whole
session,
and then you might get a different code
with your comments not fully taken
I So, there's always a chance that um
when
again, Copilot is probabilistic. So,
there's always a chance it's not going
to give me the code exactly the way that
I want it to. But remember that at the
end of the day, what this has done is
this has created
just open this up inside of a brand new
tab. This has created a brand new
branch. And so, I could go in and add in
a comment and tell Copilot, "Hey, I want
you to fix this."
But this is also a branch. So, I could
then just go in and say, "Hey, let me
create a brand new branch on that
space." Or I could go in and um
uh and then just clone that and then
just check out that branch and then go
in and manually make the changes as
well. And so, like in the situation that
you're describing where, "Hey, maybe
everything looks good, but it's just
this one file that I need to modify.
Honestly, in that situation, I think
what I would do is I would just go ahead
and
um
I would just do this is
get checkout
Yes.
And Copilot's great at generating Git
commands.
It is.
Um so uh yeah, so I could just go in and
do that. Now I could just modify
manually or like I could just work with
Copilot here then on whatever it was
that I that I was wanting to do.
Yeah.
Yeah, so can you go back to the diagram
of the NCP? Sure. That has to be
connected to your computer section to
that. So, if you're using one of these
remote agents and it's connecting to
NCP
how can it do that number one with the
remote session? Yes.
How long does that session look like in
So, um so that I I'm going to kind of
up-level all of this. So, the question
is is can it go to a remote server? Um
how long does that session last? Um etc.
And the the short answer to can it
access the remote server? Yes. Can it
act on your behalf? Yes. How long is
that going to last? That depends. Um
that um when you go to set up that
connection to that remote server, you're
going to provide a credential um for
that. So, in the case of say like the
GitHub um um MCP server then I can go in
and I can provide a token for that, but
then I can set an expiration on that
token. Yeah, for sure. Yeah. So, it's
all that's really going to depend. There
isn't anything in Copilot that's um
going to
um automatically like sign you out or
anything like that. And so, this MCP
server it can't basically pick off you
know, this is something that the actual
the agent that's running remotely has to
decide to pull from the account. It
can't basically kick off
Correct. Yeah, so it's the MCP server is
not just automatically going to be able
to do something on my behalf. I'm going
to have to indicate hey, I want to do
this. And then on top of that, I don't
think I've got it set up on here and it
would just take me a couple of minutes
to do it.
But if I go in and I make a request
that's going to kick off an MCP server,
I actually have a button that says hey,
do you want to do this? Which actually
leads me right into my next point, which
is
um
that my I I want to make sure that I'm
vetting my MCP servers just like I would
anything else that's going to access
external information, just like anything
else that's going to be able to act on
my behalf.
Sure.
Is it possible to create a GitHub issue
on behalf of another company and then
have that be assigned to their internal
team? We're getting into a lot of
specifics. Let's talk afterwards. All
right, yeah.
Um do you have visibility to what model
the coding agent uses or visibility to
how it's making the decision so we can
further profit in the future at
So for coding agent, and again I'm I'm
just to make sure that we're clear this
is where I'm on github.com. Right now
we're not exposing out the model that's
being used internally. Um and there's a
reason for that. Um because
we have a very specific type of
workload, a very specific set of
scenarios that need to
um to be accomplished here. And so the
model that we're choosing is the model
that specifically like that that we've
determined is best for doing this. There
might come a time where that starts to
get exposed out and maybe that that
allows for change. But as of right now,
it's it's specifically because it works
with this. Yes, you still have your hand
raised. One more question, quick
question. Yeah. Really good question.
Is it possible to have multiple coding
Um yeah, I mean
Like a pair of them that can make side
effects
I guess it would cost more but Yeah,
like I I I can create 100 issues and
assign all 100 of them to uh to to to
coding agent.
Yeah.
Yeah, so remember that each time that
you assign an issue to a coding agent,
it's going to create an environment
specifically for that issue. So each
issue will get its own agent. Exactly.
Yep.
Yeah.
Those instructions, right? That applies
to section? Yep.
Seems like it's going to grow so huge.
Can I do it
as opposite as like in that folder of my
own instructions instead? All right.
Yeah, kind of like a chain and
hierarchy, yeah. Instead of like having
one gigantic file. Um so
um
What you can do, and I actually have an
example of that right here. Yeah, so
you'll notice that right here, um I'm
actually
um
inside this dot instructions file, I'm
actually referencing out to another dot
instructions file.
Yep. And then on the apply to, you could
go in and start setting folders as well.
So however it is that you want that to
be set up.
Yep. Yeah.
Yeah.
Sure.
Yeah, so if you're working with coding
agent, you can configure your list of
MCP servers at the organization level or
on individual repos for
um
for anything that's going to be inside
of VS Code. And I'm not sure how others
would
would necessarily be have that set up.
You can actually just set up inside of a
repository or inside your repository
your MCP.json file, which is what I've
got right here.
And then I can just list them all here.
That now becomes part of the the
repository.
The user will then still need to set up
their own credentials because again it's
going to act on on that user's behalf.
Correct. Correct. Yep. Yeah.
Mr. Harold.
Oh, okay. Thank you.
What time is your talk?
Okay.
Yeah.
So, you know, I'm actually going to to
kind of up level this.
One of the things about using MCP
servers all up with agent mode is that
Copilot does need to figure out which
MCP server to call and when to call it.
And generally speaking it's going to be
able to do that on its own. But again,
and and and let this maybe be the number
one lesson that we pick up from from
today that if I ever see Copilot not
doing something the way that I expect it
to do, what am I going to do?
There we go. I'm going to well or even
even more generically you know, back I
used to be a tech trainer. Um
Um so I'd like literally just like go
around different companies to teach
classes. And one of the things I would
do is I would have little
little bits of candy and just like toss
them out to like the little baby Reese's
and toss this out. And I wish I had one.
But yeah, exactly. Like update your
instructions file or again like improve
your context. And so like one of the
things that you could do is if you know
for this specific type of scenario, this
is the MCP server I want you to talk to,
put it inside your instructions file.
And in fact Azure, their MCP server when
you register it, VS code will actually
prompt you and go, "Hey, do you want to
add that into your um
Here you go. There there there you go.
Um but
but if you install the Azure MCP server,
it will actually say, "Hey, you should
add this to your instructions file."
Okay. There was a lot of questions.